so you started on youtube 2005 you've
now transitioned to vine
how many followers do you have on vine
on vine over three million
over three million okay where did the
idea to
jump to vine go and how does the youtube
videos or how do the youtube videos and
the vine videos coincide or
are they two separate things um i jump
to vine because
being in social media again promoting
yourself i'm always ready to latch onto
something new in social media when it
works
a lot of apps come and go and like it's
not a you know i don't take them
seriously but if something works
i will get on that app because it's
another avenue to promote myself
so that's why i did it um do the two
coincide
not really they're separate beasts in a
way
um they're apples and oranges um vine a
six second video youtube
is longer format so they're they're
pretty separate well i know with youtube
in the past you had to be accepted to
the partner program but now anybody can
monetize
non-copyrighted stuff how does vine work
do you can you monetize the video
you can't monetize a video but there's a
lot of branding deals and branding
opportunities
so people are actually getting paid for
six seconds
of work yeah and where do you is there
like
a site where it's like almost like a
craigslist for viners where you can
offer your no there's no site but you
know
brands come reaching out uh to viners
and then
that's usually how that works so first
be on vine make the videos
and then the audience and then brands
you know if you're good and if you fit
their brand
they come calling can someone let's say
that has maybe a thousand followers on
vine
get a deal of some kind of deal or it
would have to be
much higher typically they would be
looking at someone who is like
either hundreds of thousands or over a
million
typically okay we got a little work to
do i think